- Welcome back everybody.
(audience cheering)
It's no secret I am a huge
fan of our next guest.
In fact, I was quite pleased with myself
for getting him from the
clutches of Blake Shelton
on season 21 of The Voice.
It's hard to do. It really is.
There's a lot of prayer that goes into it.
But just this year he landed a record deal
with Capitol Christian
Music Group from Team Kelly.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Give it up for Jeremy Rosado everybody.
- Thank you. Thank you so much.
- We were texting.
I'm so excited you're here.
I've been so excited to see you
because you've been, you took
off, you got a record deal,
you've been touring with Newsboys.
You've been doing, doing it.
- Yeah. It's been crazy.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- The work's been wild.
But you've been so instrumental on that.
So first of all, this is crazy.
Thank you for having me.
This is so wild.
- I'm so excited
to have you on my show.
Yeah, I was like, and we're
sitting down and chatting.
- I know. That's like, good.
- I love it 'cause you're,
you're such a talented guy.
I need to say this
because you don't hear this
always, but even Chris,
our stage manager here,
also is a stage manager at The Voice
and we literally we were just talking
while you were off camera doing
something, your mic thing.
And he was like, you know what, that dude
he is like so cool.
He's like, I can't remember everyone,
he's been doing every season of The Voice,
he's like there are people that stand out
and you're one of those people.
Because you're so cool on and off camera.
- Thank you so much.
(audience applauding)
- [Kelly] And that matters.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] And I think that's
why you're successful as well.
- Thank you. Thank you so much.
- But you say being on The Voice
gave you a second chance
at your dream, right?
- Yeah. I mean I did American
Idol like 10 years ago,
we've talked about that.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But coming off Idol and just
kind of like life happening
and having to just put music on pause.
And to be completely honest,
after like years of like chasing it
and I just kind of like let it go.
- [Kelly] Get discouraged.
- Yeah. I thought the dream was gone.
And so here 10 years later, The Voice,
like who does both shows like that.
You know what I mean?
- I know, I remember I
was just telling him this.
I didn't even know that
whenever I first got you on.
- [Jeremy] That's right.
- I had no idea.
- And I didn't tell you
I was like I'm just going to keep that-
- I know, I had no idea.
- First of all.
I was like, I don't know
if I should say that.
- No, I think I found out whenever,
I think this is the first time I found out
I was Googling you 'cause I always Google
people that I'm with and
in YouTube and see like,
what would they be good, like songs.
And I was like, this
song was on America Idol?
I was like, I had no idea.
And I was like, we were
meant to be together.
- Oh, yes, yes.
- But JLo called you Jer Bear.
- Yes.
- When you were on Idol.
That's amazing that JLo said anything.
- Can I just say the love
of my life, Jennifer Lopez.
- Oh, she's kind of the
love of mine and I'm not
even a lesbian.
- Okay, cool, cool.
- Yeah. Yeah. Like who doesn't love JLo?
- She is the love of my
life. Yeah. Jer Bear. Crazy.
- I love that.
Did that nickname stick?
- It is stuck all the time.
I mean, you JLo can't call
you something and people not
not call you that.
- [Kelly] Exactly.
- You know what I'm saying so.
- When she has named you,
you must stick with this.
- It is stuck and I'm cool with that.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Call me Jer Bear.
- Not everybody has a nickname from JLo.
I don't have one. (laughs)
I was like I want one.
You're Jer Bear. I wanna be Care Bear
just 'cause I love Care Bears
- Jer Bear and Care Bear.
- Care Bear. (laughs)
- Gonna put that in your phone.
- That's our thing. Now it's contract.
Okay. So you sang a lot of
covers on Idol and on The Voice.
- Yep.
- What's one of your favorites?
I will say my favorite is
you always impressed me with
singing these huge female icon.
like big, huge voice like songs.
- [Jeremy] Thank you.
- But what are your favorites?
- Those are my favorites.
I came onto the Voice
like super strategic.
I think coming off Idol
having like a plan of like-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Picking songs and stuff.
And so when I kind of
would pitch to you like,
Hey, I want to do Whitney,
or I want to do Celine.
- I was like. (screams)
- That's a big song,
but okay, let's do it.
- And then in in rehearsal
I'd be like, what the hell?
- [Jeremy] Yeah, yeah
- Yeah. You're so gifted.
And it's amazing just to hear
it from a male perspective,
these songs-
- That I think that's cool.
And I think that's the part
of it that kind of connects
you know what I'm saying?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Before puberty, a long time ago (laughs)
I used to sing like Mariah notes.
- Yeah. Oh my gosh. Of course you did.
Yeah.
- But that changed.
I remember one day I was in church
and I was singing the CeCe Winans song
which CeCe Winans is my, oh my God.
- Isn't CeCe and Whitney the
one that did Count On Me?
- [Jeremy] Oh yeah.
- Oh.
- We should do that at some point,
okay, throwing it out there.
- Please can we do, it's
on TV. Put this on there.
- Wait, it's in contract.
All these things.
And so I was singing the CeCe
Winans song Alabaster Box
and my voice had just begun to change.
And my mom is in the
audience and I start singing.
I'm thinking, oh, I know this, I'm good.
I start singing it.
And it's like, (voice cracks)
and my mom is like, she stands
up in the back of the church.
She's like, Bobby, let's try that again.
That wasn't so great, in front
of everyone's telling me.
I'm like, I'm never
singing again in my life.
And then I kind of adjusted it.
But I think it comes from
that starting with like
singing CeCe's music and I think
it's kind of, I think it's impressive.
You know what I'm saying?
I'll watch dudes do that.
I'm like, man, that's awesome.
So it's part of the strategy.
- And it's unexpected is what is cool too.
- That's what it was.
I wanted to like throw
things that were like,
oh wow, okay cool.
- Do you think, 'cause I
have a mama like that too,
she'll be the first one to be like,
well, could have been better.
- Oh yeah, mine too.
- But I think having that
from such a young age
I think that's why do push myself.
- [Jeremy] Yeah.
- So do you feel like that helped you?
- Oh, absolutely.
- Like inadvertently, while
you're crying after a show.
(Jeremy laughing)
You're like, oh, shoot.
- Like, oh my gosh.
No. Yeah, absolutely.
My mom is, she's man, she's incredible.
My biggest supporter yet,
she likes to tell me she's my mirror.
She's like, oh, you're
with Capital Records.
That's great.
Do something for me. You know what I mean?
Anyway, so she keeps me grounded
and I love it so much.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- They're honest.
- Yeah, they are.
- Yeah. Not all mamas,
'cause I was at Idol auditions
those people come out
and I'm like why are you lying your child?
I was like, why are you,
this is not helpful.
I had an honest mom.
I was very thankful for in that moment.
But you're also a faith
leader, which is incredible.
I grew up singing in church as well.
- Yeah.
- So how has Faith helped you
on your journey to getting here and still?
- [Jeremy] Yeah.
- 'Cause this is a hard business.
- It's hard.
I mean, I'm just starting
in this thing too,
but it's been being a worship
leader, being a faith leader,
and just being church, singing songs.
Leading people in worship has
been the foundation for me.
I started leading worship when
I was 15 years old in church.
So just growing on that
and becoming a vocalist.
Understanding being on a platform
and even though it's worship,
engaging with the crowd and with people
and what eye contact can do
when you're singing to someone.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- It just has given me so
much, you know what I mean?
it's the foundation and I love Jesus.
You know what I mean? Like that's it.
- Absolutely. I think also when you're,
I grew up singing in church as well
and I think having been
taught this isn't about me.
- [Jeremy] Yeah. Oh man.
- You're the vessel for something bigger
that's very helpful.
- And that keeps you to like-
- Keeps the nerves at bay,
keeps everything at bay.
'cause you're like, all
right, I'm just a vessel.
- There's something that I can just focus,
I can just like sit here in a second
and be like, you know what,
God use me. That's it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah. I love it.
- Oh, write that song.
Okay, so use me.
I'm just saying that's a beautiful song.
You know, 'cause you think it's gonna be
like a sad song like you
use. I'm just saying.
Okay, so you're about to,
we're writing a song right now.
- Oh my God.
I got a song with Care Bear and Jer Bear.
- Yeah, there's so many things happening.
We're gonna do the duet Count On Me.
Yes, we're singing the duet. Yeah
- Exactly.
So you're about to sing you're
single Believe You Will.
So what does that song mean?
- Song has been the most
incredible thing though.
First song on Capitol
and releasing to the fans
and it's out right now
wherever you listen to music.
But just being able to, I've lived it,
my story's kind of complicated
with my daughter, my
niece was my daughter.
- Truth is powerful.
- And exactly.
And I pulled from these
complicated situations.
I pulled so much hope out of it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I've had moments where I
first became a dad to this kid.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And trying to figure out
how I was gonna provide.
I mean, I'm 21 years old trying
to figure this out Kelly.
- Can't even imagine.
- With a kid and and all the other things
that are attached to this.
I love my sister, but she's had a struggle
that's never allowed her to
be the mom she needed to be.
So just like having to go before God
and be like I need you to show up.
I need you to do what you
promised you would do.
And like, I'm living now.
I'm sorry, I'm like in, I'm living.
- No, I'm like, you're killing me here.
- I'm living in the goodness of God.
He's been so faithful to us.
And so that's what this song is about.
(audience applauding)
I believe because I've experienced.
- [Kelly] I believe you will
- I believe you will because
I've experienced this.
- You will show up for me.
Yeah.
- Yeah. You'll do this.
And you have before God,
you've proven to me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That I'm not actually alone in this.
And so I wanted to take that
and throw it out to the message
'cause I've lived it, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so what kind of
music am I gonna put out?
I don't wanna put out nothing but
this kind of music that
allows people to connect
and be able to just draw
from those complicated
and hard situations.
Pull hope out of 'em.
And that's it for me.
- That's the best kind of song too.
And you're in your truth
and you're just saying
what happened? Testimony.
- It's hard to sing it
sometimes though 'cause-
- Oh my god, I hate myself
with some of my songs.
Why do I have to sing this again?
Yeah, yeah.
- It's tough, yeah.
- But it's important 'cause
I think that's what people
relate to and connect with.
- [Jeremy] Yeah.
- And that's our whole job, I think.
- [Jeremy] Yeah, it is.
- Yeah. Alright, well let's
hear the song now performing.
Believe You Will, give
it up for Jeremy Rosado.
(audience cheering and applauding)
(soft piano music)
♪ I don't walk by myself when I go ♪
♪ Through the valley of shadows ♪
♪ Lord I know that You're here
with me, I'm not out of reach ♪
♪ I'm everything but afraid when
I'm walking into the battle ♪
♪ See I've been in places just like this ♪
♪ What You did before You will again ♪
♪ You will turn this into something good ♪
♪ Show up right on time for me ♪
♪ Do everything You said You would ♪
♪ I believe, I believe,
I believe You will ♪
♪ Turn my sorrow into joy ♪
♪ Calm the storm with just Your voice ♪
♪ Do everything You said You would ♪
♪ I believe, I believe,
I believe You will ♪
♪ I believe that Your plan for my life ♪
♪ Is a hope and a future ♪
♪ Even in my greatest pain,
nothing goes to waste ♪
♪ Every tear I've cried
just waters the garden ♪
♪ Oh, I know it will
be worth the harvest ♪
♪ You have kept every promise,
and I know You will again ♪
♪ You will turn this into something good ♪
♪ Show up right on time for me ♪
♪ Do everything You said You would ♪
♪ I believe, I believe, I believe ♪
♪ You will turn my sorrow into joy ♪
♪ Calm the storm with just Your voice ♪
♪ Do everything You said You would ♪
♪ I believe, I believe, I believe ♪
♪ You will work miracles,
the impossible for me ♪
♪ God, I believe, yes, I believe ♪
♪ You will work miracles,
the impossible for me ♪
♪ God, I believe ♪
♪ I believe ♪
♪ Show up right on time for me ♪
♪ Do everything You said You would ♪
♪ I believe, I believe, I believe ♪
♪ You will turn my sorrow into joy ♪
♪ Calm the storm with just Your voice ♪
♪ Do everything You said You would ♪
♪ I believe, I believe, Lord I believe ♪
♪ You turn it around ♪
♪ I trust Your heart ♪
♪ And I believe, I believe,
I believe You will ♪
(audience cheering and applauding)
- One more time for Jeremy Rosado y'all.
I love him so much.
Y'all pick up his single Believe You Will
and lookout for dates
for his upcoming tour
starting next month.